la amazonía el mayor bosque tropical del
mundo está sufriendo pérdidas enormes en
agosto la deforestación aumentó en un
80% respecto al año pasado y los
incendios han batido
récords el mes de agosto Battle récord
como el más afectado por incendios en la
amazonía desde 2010
cifras que acusan un gran retroceso
medioambiental en el país en plena
campaña electoral a menos de un mes de
las elecciones presidenciales Los
Defensores ambientales culpan al
presidente Yair bolsonaro por acelerar
el deterioro del Bosque
los últimos cuatro años tuvimos un
mandato extremadamente antiambiental con
el discurso y la práctica fomentó El
Avance de la ilegalidad en la amazonía
Y es que desde que fue elegido en 2018
bolsonaro recortó la vigilancia
medioambiental y aumentó los permisos de
agricultura y minería comercial en el
Amazonas políticas que han dañado la
región clave para el parte de la crisis
ambiental algo que el presidente ha
negado ante el mundo
en la amazonía brasileña más del 80% de
la selva tropical permanece intacta al
contrario de lo que informan los medios
de comunicación nacionales e
internacionales
afirmaciones rebatidas por los medios y
también por el candidato favorito de las
elecciones de octubre el ex presidente
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva que ha
prometido una protección más estricta de
la amazonía con mayores controles para
frenar las prácticas ilegales y más
empleos para desempeñar estas tareas
pondremos el tema del clima como
prioridad máxima lo que significa que no
habrá términos medios la
grandeforestación y los incendios
amenazan el delicado ecosistema del
conocido como pulmón del mundo un
problema que requiere de intervención
gubernamental